1916 and house bill
14 26 and
before we begin our discussion
i will read the piece that is required
for all chairs which is as chair of the
resources recreation and development
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covet 19 pandemic and in
accordance with the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 20 2004
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting which
was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that we are a
providing public access to the meeting
by telephone with
additional access possibilities by video
or other electronic means
we are utilizing zoom for this
electronic meeting
all members of the committee and select
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by clicking on the following
website address
zoom dot u s slash j
9 3 5 6 7 5 5
6 2 5 4 or dialing one of the following
phone numbers one three one two
six two six six seven nine nine
or one nine two nine two zero five
six zero nine b
providing public notice of the necessary
information for accessing the meeting
we previously gave notice to the public
of the necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is printed in the house
calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public body during the
meeting if there are problems with
access
if anybody has a problem please call 271
3600 or email hcs
at ledge.state.nh.us
d adjourning the meeting if the public
is unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us
and i thank them very much for their
effort joel anderson is the meeting host
additional staff providing support are
pam smarling and brad greenland
this is a work session on bills referred
to the resources recreation and
development committee for interim study
and an executive session will follow
copies of the interim study bills have
been posted on the main page of the
general court website
under the heading remote meetings let's
start the meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
because this is required by the right to
know law
and remember to unmute yourself when you
are uh
announcing your presence and i will ask
the clerk to call the role
vice chairman mays shut the door please
present i'm in my home my daughter is in
the room
uh working in another computer working
from home
representative spang uh judith spang
i am alone in my in my room
sounds sad okay
representative parkhurst represents
us at home alone okay
representative thomas you need to unmute
yourself
okay i am home alone okay representative
grassy
representative grassy is here home at
alone
representative bushway i'm at my home
and i'm alone in the room
representative cohen our representative
cullen is here alone however
representative henry parker is on my
speaker phone which is placed
next to my computer speaker so he's
participating
representative noel is home and alone
the clerk is home and alone
representative renzullo i am
i am uh at home at the desk
and i am alone in the room okay
representative gould representative
gould here and alone
representative horgan president at work
and alone okay representative feeney
are you in prison alone at home
representative harp i am in my office
and alone at this time
representative hopson i am home
in my office alone representative
spelaine
chairman smith i am here and i
am alone in my office okay the roll call
is complete
thank you very much madam clerk so the
first bill we will be
uh discussing is house bill 1316
relative to ohrv trails known as ride
the wilds
and the floor is open for anyone who
would like
and if there's not anyone raising their
hand which i don't
see i will give a brief overview i was
going through the file
of this morning and on this bill opening
up ride the wilds
the letter from the department of
natural and cultural resources that the
committee received
uh states that this bill would
circumvent the statutes about
the sustainability the suitability of
state lands for ohrv
trails and they state that there is a
long established process for evaluating
opening up uh trails on state lands for
ohrvs
and this bill would bypass that process
and
also uh they state as we heard in
testimony
from a few different people that the
department had just culminated a
multi-year
nash stream forest management plan
and this opening up more trails
was not part of that discussion in fact
they specifically rejected
the in the management plan rejected that
uh
process
comments from the committee anything to
add anything to say
a move
are you taking motions
um i've raised my hand
oh okay i see uh representative renzolo
has raised his hand and representative
spang
we are just to answer your question um
this is a work session so we're not
really
i mean we can i think we should have a
little more discussion before we do a
motion
yes representative renzolo yes if you
recall
that this bill also had
uh as part of the uh the hearing
there was a a amendment
introduced to it concerning hoyt pond in
concord which is
you know very different from the bill
itself and in fact the
amendment at hoyt pond had more
discussion
and more public input than the actual
original text of the bill
so the
the uh the the issue
with this bill is with that and that
amendment even though we did not
pass that amendment because we didn't i
don't think we ever came to a vote on it
that this whole the whole issue
together uh this should be taken this
this discussion should also include
that amendment and my feeling personally
is that we should make just no
recommendation on this
and if someone wants to bring something
back
just let it happen uh but
we shouldn't take a position on it
because we really haven't uh
haven't come to a conclusion on uh
uh on on the on the uh
on any on on much of anything as far as
and i don't think we're ever going to
get to duke to be able to do that
uh in the time allotted so just let it
let it go on to uh next year if somebody
wants to bring it back
fine if not fine too
yeah representative ghouls
oh you have to unmute yourself
thank you yes i understand what andy is
saying and uh
it seems as though there are like two
bills in this bill
uh both hoytmash and uh where i have
visited as a matter of fact
and then uh the nash stream forest and
uh
as you just mentioned the management
plan uh
uh does not permit it and then h.b 660
enacted last year requires in dnci to
prepare master plan for ohrb
trails and cross county that was some of
our testimony that we received
so it seems as though there's work i
guess you'd have to say that has to be
done
or that uh these uh
studies are involved with am i correct
in saying that
well the the um regarding the amendment
that was brought in about the
hoyt pond uh weight road pond
the committee did not adopt that
amendment but one of the reasons we did
vote to interim study
is because of that issue and we hoped
to like have a field trip and go out
there and work on it and call in
stakeholders and because of the
pandemic we pretty much were not able to
do any of that
so we haven't learned anything new since
the public hearing
in my in my mind i hoped to get down
there this summer
and take a look at it and and look at
the wildlife and look at the situation
there but
we weren't able to so i mean the
that's you know but the but the nash
stream one yeah there's work already
being done on all of those issues
and it seems like that that part of the
bill is definitely
which is the only bill we have before us
but that doesn't prevent us from making
comments
representative spang thank you and then
representative noel and representative
cohen
sorry i may not be seeing your hands in
a timely fashion
i don't know if this is a uh just a
matter of
uh of logistics or whether
it's a matter of how we
talk about this i there was a nice word
for that and it's not coming to me
but um i i'm confused about the status
of the amendment um i think
representative renzullo said it was not
it was not formally introduced
which is different from our saying that
it was not adopted
if it was not formally introduced then
it's not really part of this bill
is that correct yes
so my feeling is under those
circumstances that we should
not address it since it's not part of
the bill
and we should encourage anyone who wants
to pick up on that
issue to bring in a bill next year
that deals with this as a legitimate
bill
um representative renzolo
i see uh representative i mean noelle
and
cohen with their hands up and then i'll
get to you but joel did you have
something to say
just on this one point about it being uh
whether or not the amendment was
formally
introduced um i believe the committee
actually had a
a separate public hearing on the
amendment
after the original public hearing on the
bill
so in that sense it was certainly
formally before the committee
thank you representative noel
yes thank you madam chair uh
thinking looking at the information that
we we have on the
nash stream portion of hp 1316
the nash stream management plan a is a
body a multi-member
body who's tasked with uh responsibility
of evaluating the use of that
that property and i know that the local
club
followed their their procedures in
making an application
to make a bypass route to get the ohrv
traffic off the roads and it was a
pretty thorough
piece of work in their submission
said the nash stream management
group considered the use
of the nastream property
not an appropriate use by ohrvs of the
nat stream property not an appropriate
use and decided
not to allow the modification the trail
modification requested
and i think that's appropriate because
that is the structure that was
established when nash stream
was put in place uh i believe this
bill comes at
the whole issue from the legislative
point of view and
and by fiat is trying to determine that
a no hrd trail can be placed in
nash stream which i don't think is a
good precedent
uh it is actually the
same issue we're considering with the
hoyt road marsh
where the the senate
finance committee preemptively
deemed that motorcycles would not be
allowed on the marsh
by legislative fiat no public hearing
was held
it was just determined arbitrarily
so i am i'm predisposed to
to not uh allowing
ohrv trails on ride the wilds or not
supporting this bill
thank you uh representative cohen and
then representative renzolo
thank you very much madam chairperson
yes i've i've
gone through all the information that
we've been presented
and although we're not voting at this
time
as a workshop i would say that i see
that the amendment
if we were voting on that and the um
original bill on that stream
are both attacks on our environment and
as a steward
of the environment the people of new
hampshire i can't support either of
those
and if there was a motion to not
pass these bills whatever that motion
would be i would
definitely absolutely support let it not
passing me not recommending these bills
to be
revised for the next year by somebody
else
um i just before we before we get to
representative renzolo
um joel uh wendy thomas has written that
she can't find the link and asks you to
send it
if you haven't done that already okay
representative
yes got me now can you hear me now
okay uh i think
with the it has been brought out that we
did have a here
there was a hearing on this in fact if
i'm not mistaken maybe i
got my times my dates mixed up wasn't
this part of the joint hearing that we
okay but but at any at any rate
the issue around the hoyt pond
and how that whole business was uh
went down and how that that change in
use
occurred has real
merit and
that was part of the the that was of
was an important part of the discussion
and
if we if we vote just to not
recommend
or or to vote but basically vote against
uh the passage of the bill or
not in favor of the bill rather
it's it is it puts
it is also a vote again a vote for
the way that change and use occurred
and i propose what i'm proposing is that
we just simply have no recommendation
and then if someone wants to bring bring
up the
white pond issue that's
they can do it without it being uh
pre-prejudiced by this by the uh the
vote of this committee
the the choices we have
are we recommend this for future
legislation
and i use the term loosely we recommend
this issue for future legislation or we
do not recommend this for future
legislation
those are the two choices you can't say
uh we're not making any recommendation
you have to do one or the other and
one of the possible ones would be to not
recommend
future legislation on the bill as
introduced
however the committee did hear testimony
on an amendment which was brought in
uh and if we were not able to study it
and if someone wishes to bring
a bill in related to that
i don't know how you'd write it even but
um
you know to say the bill is introduced
we do not recommend
however we should address i think
because one of the reasons we voted to
interim study the bill
was to review this issue
the the ice racing so i
think somehow that needs to be
incorporated
with our we don't recommend for the bill
but there are other issues that should
possibly be discussed
i don't know how to word it but i mean
you know
does that sound correct to you
representative renzo
it sounds correct but you know the
the you know it's all it's all about our
wording
uh yeah yeah what is it depends how it's
worded
i mean uh i don't want to
prejudice somebody's of somebody's
uh project pre-prejudice this bill
uh leased the part around point pond if
it right
because the whole business didn't the
whole
adjudication of that did not go through
the proper channels
i mean it was done by it was it was
stuck onto
hb2 and it was we never even knew about
it and neither did the people
so it was it was an affront to the way
we do that we do business in the
legislature
and if someone wants to bring that up
i don't i don't want to prejudice that
at all
okay
members of the committee representative
spang
sorry let's get this down i couldn't
agree more
with with representative renzolo
um it really infuriates me
that um that this sleight of hand was
carried on
with it
[Music]
kind of a sneak attack
on the the residents of that area
and also the users that's not to say
that i think that
racing motorcycles on hoyt pond
uh is something that if it were a
decision that were being made
afresh that i would think
that it was a good idea
i'm not sure that from an ecological
point of view
i feel that it is particularly damaging
to be having uses on ice we certainly
allow
snowmobiles on ice we allow uh
huge car races on winnipesaukee
so in my mind and from an environmental
point of view
i don't have any big problems with it i
think that
in terms of public recreation and we
keep coming up against this
motorized recreation and the
neighborhoods
um that there are
issues that need to be resolved but
certainly more equitably if this were
an issue that was being tacked on
and by finance for something that we
were absolutely against
say opening up nash stream
i think that we would be we would be up
in arms
that said um
i do agree with representative ren zullo
that it would be great if we could put
something in our report
that indicated that we weren't thrilled
with this way of doing things that we
maybe we could put it tactfully and i'm
sure there are other people who are
better at tack than i am
but it would um say something like
because the issue was because of the way
this was enacted
we feel that it was never uh
it was never vetted the way it needed to
be
and um we would not you know
[Music]
we would suggest that if it continues to
be
a problematic issue that um
legislation be brought forward to enable
um this to be looked at more fully the
other question is
does fish and game need to have
legislation
and um that's another you know i don't
know whether where they're standing
on this whether they'd be inclined to do
it
without legislation um
i think it'd be really great to make the
the um
the senate have a task force on it
but uh you know either at any rate my
point is we should have
a little something in there that says
that we
we think that the this was not done
and an open process that needs to still
happen on the
so a lot of the things you've brought up
judith um
are related to things we would have
done in an interim study yes if we had
the
if we had the space and time and
everything
um representative grassy if you're
handed yes i do because it shows me as
logged in twice
uh that is representative wendy thomas i
sent her my link
and it logged her in as me she hasn't
been able to get in on the other links
that
she was sent they were giving her error
messages so i sent her my link
and it shows up as me logging in a
second time
great we'll rename her thank you so yeah
that that
this is me um logging in so help you
sorry about that yeah they're gonna
change your name so you're not chuck
grassy two times do you have video wendy
or are you on a phone
no no i'm on a computer that this one
does not have a
camera okay or a working camera i should
say
other comments from the committee i
don't see any hands raised during the
arms waving
[Music]
uh representative rome uh representative
thomas wendy thomas are you alone in the
room
so do we have any other discussion on
this
should we take a straw vote on
a motion to i mean this is not a real
motion because we're in a work session
not a executive session we'll have the
executive session
later but i just want oh hen uh
representative noel i see your hand is
up
yes it's a point of order question sure
madam chair uh if if we do choose to
vote on this
are we also voting on the amendment at
the same time
the vote is whether to recommend for
future legislation on the original bill
or not recommend legislation on the
original bill
included in the report
could be would be which is kind of what
i was getting at with a straw vote
um something about the
addressing the amendment which did have
a public hearing but we never
that make sense that makes sense yeah
that makes sense thank you
so representative smith yes i'm sorry
i i kind of missed i was doing something
else are you talking about doing a straw
poll
is that or yeah i'm just a little
worried about
um just in terms of i guess it wasn't
consider to vote or not um or if you
just um
uh because then it's supposed to be a
roll call um
so it's fine to take a a vote on it um
i'm just a little worried about people
if you can kind of come to consensus or
you could kind of ask people
does that make sense sort of and maybe
yeah but i think that's what i'll do
anything that kind of getting close to a
vote um you need to be careful about
yeah
yeah um representative maze and then
representative hobson
and representative mays you have to yeah
thank you madam chair
i i think if we were going to be looking
at a not recommended refugee legislation
um i could be comfortable with that
because hoyt pond is not going to go
away
that legislative there is going to be
legislation to come back
next term on that that particular issue
uh
uh if if only
by the by the folks that don't want it
and then you're going to get some
counteraction on the folks that really
are passionate about
using that that facility for that so
uh if we're looking at a general kind of
uh feeling i would be comfortable in
going with our
are not recommended not recommending for
future legislation because we're pretty
much
knowledgeable what the nash stream folks
have done up there
and and their commission in looking for
the welfare of their area
so i think we're good on what we've
talked about in the committee
okay and just to clarify um the law now
states that you cannot
be on your motorcycle on the ice
in concord on hoyt road pond
um let's see representative hobson
uh thank you madam chair i just wanted
to say that i echo
the um statements of representative
spang and
representative ron zulo um
it's been a confusing issue to me
because i haven't seen the actual spot
um so a field trip for sure would be
uh would clear it up for me because i'm
a visual person but
um yeah i so i'll just leave it at that
i could go on but
um yeah i mean the
um if the if we are all on the committee
um starting in january
we could do a winter field trip and see
what it looks like in the winter without
the ice skating but just to see what it
is and then
um and you know and because i'm sure
there will be
legislation introduced about this issue
and we just need to i think in our
report
recognize that we understand this is an
issue that needs further study
but the major but the main part of the
bill we don't recommend so it's
it's kind of a challenging thing we have
is there anyone who would like to speak
and
say they agree or don't agree or
whatever and then we can end the work
sessions
so representative horgan are you feeling
i love your northern lights behind you
um
are you okay with what has been
discussed uh
by representative renzolo and
representative spang
i am my recommendation would be uh for
not
future legislation okay
i'm here and what do you think are you
uh what do you think of what's been
discussed
everything has been discussed i agree
with and um
i don't think this thing should go any
further than it already has
uh it needs a lot more work and as
one person said it's going to keep
coming back and back and back so
um i'm in complete compliance with
everyone
president spang and uh president renzo
said absolutely i agree with him
okay thank you and representative cohen
since you're already unmuted
you already made your votes you've made
your opinion noted anything
different nothing's changed in my mind
in the last four minutes no
yes i mean i agree uh with um what
representative spanning representative
zulu said i think we need to um you know
let this one run its course now
and and and let it go for what happens
down the line
okay and representative yvonne thomas
you have to unmute yeah i did uh no i
agree
i think that this was like a backdoor
bill and
it really should come up before the
committee
in in a new form okay
thank you and representative grassy
i'm sorry go ahead do you are you kind
of on the same page with everybody else
yes i i don't think we should have any
further action on this bill
if anybody wants to bring anything in
next year that's that's fine
yes i agree with renzo representative
ren solo et cetera
okay and representative feeney
yes i agree also because of the
amendment and how it was before
okay and representative harm
yes i'm in agreement with uh
representative ren zulu and
representative spang
for all the comments that were
previously made okay and representative
wrong i see you have your hand up
yeah i also wanted to state my agreement
with the consensus
of the committee i think the issues
raised in this bill can be best
addressed through different bills that
are are more specific to the issue
the language in this bill should just
should just go away and i don't
recommend this
this specific bill moving forward you
mean the ride the wilds part
yeah okay and representative wendy
thomas
yes well i'm a little late to this party
but um based on the discussion that i've
heard and the discussions that we've had
previously
i'm in full agreement okay and i think
representative hobson you already made
your
point but okay
did i miss anybody representative mays i
think you had already spoken
representative spang has her hand up
again
yep done mute sorry
um the whole thing where we're talking
about how we think it ought to be
that it ought to be looked at further
which seems to fly in the face of our
saying that
we don't recommend it for further
legislation
the only the only bill we're really
voting on is is the ride the wilds part
the nash stream
the other is
not in the bill so you can't really
right but we're talking about what we
might want to put in our
blurb yeah thinking that um
i'm not i i would feel comfortable about
saying not being comfortable with
future legislation until we
have given fish and game the opportunity
to look into this um on in their own
terms
so i would say we don't need future
legislation
unless fish and game said that they're
not able to deal with it on their own
it's it's a it has to be done in
legislation because
legislation is what outlawed the
motorcycle riding on the pond
right so it's in statute
so i mean at the very least the study
committee
on ice racing on ponds in new hampshire
you know but or else to you know but
that's
we don't need to get into the
nitty-gritty of what a piece of
legislation would look like
i in my opinion my thought is we just
want to recognize
that we understand this is an important
issue to some people
and that more work needs to be done on
it but
we don't even have an amendment it's
just kind of a nebulous
thing there okay thank you
does that make sense yeah yes chris
so any further discussion on this uh
bill
if not i'll close the work session on
and move on to
[Music]
and house bill 1426 is requiring an
off-highway recreational vehicle club to
have certain tests performed on a rail
trail
and open for discussions i would like to
speak to that
yes representative thomas yes thank you
um
so when this bill was originally uh put
in it was
specifically because of the ohrv
traffic causing a lot of dust um and a
lot of noise
uh which impacted a butters health
um but then it was raised that um
there's other other people use rail
trails that
that um like electric bikes and and
horses and that kind of stuff that
raised dust
and so this bill although it's well
intentioned i don't think it should go
anywhere and i think another bill should
be resubmitted
next year or the following year to
establish
best practices for rail trails similar
to what they have in massachusetts which
is what
i sort of based this on okay so
it is my it is my my uh opinion that
uh this bill shouldn't go anywhere okay
sorry uh i don't know about this message
use this law that
representative thomas was talking about
but
uh i just want a clarification about
these tests would be performed on only
on rail trails
if ohrvs wanted to be on a rail trail
is that correct that was the original
intent oh i'm sorry go ahead
representative gould
when a bill is interim study the bill is
effectively dead
and so we would either recommend
no further legislation on the issue of
testing of rail trails for fugitive dust
or
other problems or not recommend
for future legislation on the issue the
bill could look like anything
if there is bill a bill introduced yes
okay
but this uh is just for rail trails now
that i would be voting on
correct yeah the bill well the bill the
original bill was to require
ohrv clubs to pay for testing
and we learned early on that because
first of all ohrv clubs are not the only
people using the trails the rail trails
in the state and do we would we if we
were going to test for toxic substances
would we want to test just new trails or
trails that are you know it just seemed
like there was a lot more to
unravel in this which is why we interim
studied it
um so probably uh it should have for the
study
inside well i don't know we'll have to
um representative spang and then
representative wendy thomas again
there seems to have been a
misunderstanding
that came out of ols has an
unfortunate habit of making up
misleading titles for bills
sometimes they can be very destructive
um i think uh for example this one
it does the title says that the club
has to pay for it the bill says
that it has to be paid for by the
municipality
person or organization seeking the
conversion
so it doesn't say just ohrv
clubs it could be a municipality
so if our decision is being made because
we don't feel that we should have
that we shouldn't have the clubs pay for
it
then it's we're doing a disservice to
um yes and so i just wanted to make a
clarification what i referred to as the
best practices for rail trails from
massachusetts
that is not a bill that is that is a
document that
is followed for rail trail management in
in massachusetts and i think that that's
kind of what we
what i was looking for in this bill and
that i wanted
um rail trails to be tested for toxic
substances i wanted um to make sure that
if
rail trails are opened up to people that
they follow certain guidelines
um regarding fugitive dust and um
uh impact to local uh vegetation
and and that kind of i mean so
i think that that this bill has evolved
into something
that is that is more sort of more of a
management
plan for the use of rail trails in new
hampshire
and i see judith has a question yeah i
still
uh
so what's the difference between uh
so you don't feel that we're ready
to actually enact um this
this requirement right you feel that it
is something that should be subject to
to study or uh
what's the difference be between what
you have
have submitted and what you are really
after
so so don't get into the nitty-gritty of
the bill that we already decided wasn't
fit to pass
just as exactly right i just wanted to
know what's happening to the issue
well that's what we're here to discuss
what's going to happen
what what her thinking was when she
decided that where she thinks this
should go
and why well
that's okay well representative thomas i
see you have your hand up so
yeah just to further this discussion um
originally my thinking was that the ohrv
club
would be required to pay for this
because they're doing the most damage
but i don't it was brought to my
attention that
other other um communities use the rail
trails
and that it's it's it could be perceived
as
unfair that they that they have to pay
for this
um i'm all for you know in some kind of
a committee or commission
making them pay for partial payment on
this
because i do think that they they put in
an extraordinary load on these rail
trails
but but if i'm talking about all rail
um then it's then it's not fair to sort
of
put the burden on one club
so that's where i think some sort of a
rail trail committee or commission
is is going to be needed to to establish
best practices
around new hampshire and and maybe
they'll decide that you know up north
where there's a lot of usage of the rail
trails maybe
maybe ohrvs you know should be required
to pay
some of the cost
yeah i i think one of the things as well
is that we want to take a look at what
massachusetts is doing as far as
protection of the trails
as well i think that's something that
representative thomas has mentioned a
couple of times
um this is certainly something that's
important the
ohrvs probably do the most as far as
disrupting these beds and causing the
the
dust which has uh quite a bit of
hazardous material as we found out in
one of our hearings
in it um but let's take a look at what
some of the other states are doing
before we rush into this and i think
that's why this probably needs a little
more work
at least it needs some investigation of
what's been created out there to
protect and develop these trails in
other states and then maybe we can bring
another bill back in at a later date
okay
i see no other hands raised does anyone
else have anything to
add to this anyone who hasn't spoken
[Music]
so um i i
this morning i was reading the interim
study report that was published in the
calendar when we voted to interim study
this
and as a result of that
rather than just saying this does not
need
future legislation i came up with
something to the
re recommending future legislation to
form a study committee to us
to learn which tests would be need to be
conducted to determine the extent of the
presence of hazardous materials what
kinds of remediation would be expected
the cost of such remediation
additionally the committee with advice
from experts could determine best
management practices for opening new
rail trails for recreational use
so that kind of takes out the who's
paying for it and it just
puts it into a study committee that's
kind of what i came up with
um i'll definitely take some comments i
see representative renzola with his
okay uh i like that
i mean uh it takes the
they're they're if if there's there's
there's a it's an issue
but it's a complicated issue and
rather than spend all of the time
uh once the if when a bill comes forward
to spend all of this time
of going through all of the
ramifications and all of the nuances
of this issue if you put it into a study
committee or a commission
and who has have people spend the time
to actually work out all of the all of
the problems and all of the issues
and then come back with a recommendation
yeah uh
i don't i especially if if this covet
thing goes into
into january we're not going to be able
to do much on
on any on anything in the way of
extended work sessions or things like
that so i think
what you're proposing is probably a
pretty good idea unless
i'm missing something okay
any other comments
so if there's nothing else to say
then i'll nothing else to say i'll close
okay we've closed the work session on
house bill 1426.
now we're going into uncharted territory
um i'll open the executive session
on
house bill 1316
[Music]
relative to the ohrv trails known as
and i'm looking for a motion and
representative rum has her hand raised
yes i move that we not recommend
a second second i didn't see who
seconded that
can you raise your hand whoever made the
second
representative bushway makes the second
okay
and now representative when i'm now
we're looking for discussion
yes and um i actually also agree that we
should not
go forward with this um and there are a
few reasons one
is that towns right now are taking
action because of covid
um you you might have read that they've
they've banned um
some ohrv traffic on roads because of
uh young drivers um they're currently
up north in the middle of lawsuits about
this
um and because of the the covet epidemic
um or pandemic i should call it um
there's been limited
use uh throughout the summer so
i i don't necessarily think it's a bad
idea however i think we need to wait
until the dust settles to see what comes
out of all of these actions
before we um even think about proposing
any kind of solutions
thank you representative renzullo
uh i did not hear anything in the motion
to around mentioning the hoyt road
issue
yeah and
if that's if if it's not in a motion in
some manner
that that issue be uh
in the in what is written about this in
the actual
report then i cannot spoil the motion
okay um i don't believe
that we can actually address it in the
motion because
the amendment was not adopted and is not
part of the bill
it wasn't like uh it was no motion was
made
to ought to pass as amendment as amended
so the
amendment is not part of it i think we
need to make a
so-called gentleman's or general
person's agreement that we're going to
include that and that
that needs to be i believe that
that needs to be included in in my mind
it needs to be included in the report
but i don't think it can be
in the motion and joel uh perhaps you
can
clarify for us what the what the rules
are
right i mean i guess the formal motion
is the the simple one
recommended or not recommended for
future legislation
um and um so i i think along with that
though can
go in understanding um by the
by the person who made the motion and
and um
and through discussion that that will be
um included in the report
um so i think that would be part of the
you could have that discussion right now
um and and people could say yes i would
like to have i think that should
definitely be um in the the actual
um paragraph or whatever that's written
up uh addressing the hoyt
road um situation so in terms of whether
it's
part of the formal motion that's a fine
point i think
um um but i think uh resident run could
express that she feels that that should
be
okay representative ensulo did you want
to
did you have any further questions on
that i mean
for the record i would like to have
someone say
and part of that motion is that that
beings
that there be inclusion that the hoyt
road issue
uh is not uh
this that this recommendation does not
pray is not the prejudice the white road
issue
or does not have the uh
does not affect the hoyt road issue it
anyway
as there are still there are still
issues to be
to be discussed and to be terror
clarified
and cared and care of relative to the
hoyt road issue
and i believe that we did a
i asked everybody on the committee
during the work session
if they supported that you know that
that we would include the white
road marsh the interim study report
remember what was in the work session is
in the work session
oh no no i know that this is another
meeting yeah oh i know it is
yeah um representative rome
and then uh representative cohen and
then representative thomas
um represent ron zulo there are there
are two things we can do right now
one is a motion not to recommend for
future legislation and or
to recommend for future legislation
those are the only two things we can do
however the committee report which i
drafted as a result of our work session
let me read that to you and see if that
captures your concerns
representative smith provided an
overview of the state
process for opening trails members of
the committee shared their views
the point that hoyt hoyt road pond
motorcycle racing was not vetted through
the committee process with public
hearing
rather through hb2 was shared as a
serious concern
the bill requires further study on the
issues raised
the committee expressed agreement that
this bill should not move forward but
the issues
raised should be studied further does
that capture
your concerns i'll agree with that
okay maybe youtube maybe you too can
can final you know i mean definitely
i would share say you know
the inputs so we make sure we get it
right okay okay
so that both sides of the aisle agree
okay andy i'll
i'll type this up i'll send it to you
representative smith and to you
representative
renzolo um you know once we finalize
that this will go to
the clerk on the 16th okay
okay okay uh representative cohen
yes so i understand i think i agree with
representative wrong
and i think with representative renzullo
but as far as the vote we're doing right
now
so if we vote i want to put the um
mass stream issue as no
so if we vote the way it is that happens
right if it doesn't address
even though i'm against hoyt pawn
doesn't address it is that correct
we are addressing no further action on
the issue of
nash stream which is what the bill is
and then we're going to make a comment
on
the amendment which we had a public
hearing on but did not
add to the bill will that comment
be in the committee report oh yeah yeah
your report on the bill that we're
voting on
which both pardon
will that with what you just said be on
the committee
report on the workshop or the committee
report
on the vote we're about to take there is
no committee report on the work session
it would be the final report from the
committee
that's fine i understand it's kind of
like the committee agrees
that nash stream should not be open to
further
ohrv use but this amendment which was
introduced
we feel like we needed to do more work
on it but we couldn't
and and when we interim study the bill
you know it effectively killed the whole
bill and the amendment for the season
but more work is required on it but it's
not part of the bill
you know it's just it's convoluted but
we'll figure out a way to write it so
that the point gets across
so when someone goes to introduce
legislation
in november about hoy road marsh they
will be able to look at this and say
oh okay the committee was going to do
more work on this
okay i understand i can support the uh
motion hoover makes it to not take any
action you know
this bill dies and i can support the
committee write-up that you're proposing
will happen around us i'll be fine with
both of those
thank you and representative i did want
to say that
we did have a public hearing on the
amendment
um oh i was referring to the inclusion
of the hoyt road
ban um that was done on hb2
uh the original that's what i was right
okay got it representative thomas
yes um thank you i just wanted to
clarify something my statements earlier
were actually towards another bill
however i kind of got that yes however i
still support the motion
along with the uh enhanced clarification
members of the committee um it would be
nice if we
redid what we did before uh as
when we were in the work session so that
we have it
clearly stated that we're all in
agreement if you were in agreement
so start again with
okay i support the conversation okay
great
representative harb yes i support the
discussion
yeah uh representative grassley
yep i'm in support yep representative
yes
okay i think you i said yes
okay great representative
yep i support the conversation as well
okay representative bushway
yes representative mays
yes i support it representative gould
representative i didn't hear you
representative cool supports it
yeah representative feedy
yes support okay great representative
spang you
discussed it so i'm
i don't want to put words in your mouth
that's how i support okay
and representative smith yes i support
it also
did i miss anybody yes oh representative
parker
i sorry i was talking over you so i
didn't hear you could you please repeat
representative supports it okay great
and representative thomas i see your
hand up yes i support it as well
okay great all right so are we ready for
a vote representative cohen
okay thank you and representative wendy
no i had had it up and um i just because
i had not been called so i was just
letting you know that i also supported
it
oh okay yep great so are we ready for a
okay um the motion on the floor is to
not recommend
um this hb 1316
for future legislation so a yes vote is
to support that motion
vice chairman mays yes
yes representative grassy yes
representative bushway yes
representative cohen yes
representative noel yes
the clerk votes yes representative wendy
thomas
yes representative renzullo
yes representative gould yes
representative horgan yes representative
feeney
yes representative gunski
representative harb yes representative
hobson
yes representative spelaine
chairman smith yes okay the motion
passes
17 to zero great
thank you everyone that went fairly
smoothly
um next up
if the clerk is ready we have house bill
1426 related to
requiring off-highway recreational
vehicle clubs to have certain tests
performed on a rail trail
i move that we not recommend
this bill hb 1426 for further
legislation
i think the discussion we had in work
session captures the issues around this
bill
i believe were we not look i'm sorry
representative mays i said were we not
looking to possibly recommend
the the issued to study commission
to create a study commission to take a
further look at this yes we were
which would mean we would want to uh
have this be recommended for future
legislation then that legislation would
um so wrong
okay um my question
is is the two motions that we have
available to us
when it says future legislation is that
specific to the language of
um hb 1426 or is it just
concepts that come up during the
discussion of that bill
1426 is dead it will not be regenerated
in its present form well it could be
someone could introduce is
exactly the same but i think we're
voting on the issue
we the the motion would be the issue
needs more study
i mean the issue recommending future
legislation could be recommending a
study committee
it could be recommending you know who
pays for it differently
it could be you know a study you know
making a recommendation could be a
number of things
okay um but not recommending to me
says this issue is not worth looking at
again
okay um i do support
um anyone that comes forward in the next
term
with a bill to form a study commission
or study committee or commission
so i will withdraw my motion to not
recommend
okay and would the person was represent
it was representative gold
representative gould you seconded it
do you want to withdraw your motion yes
i shall
okay great all right and chairman smith
i'd like to make a new motion
to recommend um
hb 1426
for um future legislation and i would
like to second that please
and discussion
i i just think we're doing our due
diligence and doing it that way
uh so i i i support this uh
it's certainly needed and and we'll go
from there
um would anyone
i mean basically this is the executive
session so we really need to clarify
what we are voting on and what we want
renzullo
um let me make certain i can hear you
okay again we need to have
as part of we need to have in in the i
don't know if it's in the motion
or as part of this discussion
an agreement that what we're really
talking about
is for a study commission or study
committee
and not go beyond beyond that we know
that there's an issue
we're here but we need we we
don't we think it has to be studied
outside of the committee process
okay any other uh
representative harb and then
representative thomas
thank you madam chair uh i agree with uh
representative renzullo i thought it
might be appropriate and i'd have to ask
joel
if at the end of the motion we tack on
to it
a study commission or committee
instead of leaving it just general new
legislation i don't know if we can
add that at the end of the motion so
it's pretty specific
to whit t-o-w-i-t colon
a study commission or committee
i'd recommend that we add that if if
that's possible to do
yeah i think i mean basically we are
making this motion
and then we are putting in a committee
report
and the committee report would explain
what we
hope to achieve with our motion
um joel correct me if i'm wrong i mean i
don't think we can add anything else to
the motion itself
um just like before when i spoke to this
it's sort of a
fine point i mean i think the formal
motion is
recommended or not recommended for
future legislation i think
through um discussion as we did before
on the prior bill we
became very clear to the um the
committee members um and
what the agreement was in terms of what
that report will include
uh and in this case it would be in terms
of a study
committee um so um it's in in terms of
if you can kind of add that as a kind of
a parenthetical
to the motion i mean i imagine you could
um
but um it just uh depends on how the the
chair wants to proceed well if we can
add it to the motion
um
that's fine with me i would just say it
was just it would
it could just be a just a it wouldn't be
the actual report
i would say it would just be maybe if it
would make
members feel better about it it could
just be a short little sentence added to
it that
it shall the the um uh the
recommendation for future legislation
is for the purposes of creating a study
representative brown yeah my
understanding
from discussions with the house clerk
that the
um the the two motions that are possible
for us to recommend or not recommend are
pretty
um that that's going to be pretty firm i
think any recommendations
we make that are specific to a study
committee commission
only can be included in the committee
report the executive committee report
so i i would not advise to alter
the standard wording for the motions
that we have available to us
and i would agree in terms of the form
that's filled out there's only
emotions and so the you know the in when
it
shows up as published in the house
calendar
that's it's going to say that the
committee recommends or not recommends
future legislation
and then after that will be the the um
the report
right and so that's where it would be
i am latia i see representative thomas
has her hands up and representative harb
has his hand up also
okay um in this recommendation for a
study committee or commission
can we drill down a little bit and say
that the
the purpose of it is to establish best
practices for rail trail management in
new hampshire
that would be in the report okay all
right i'm happy with that thank you
representative harm yes i would uh
go along with supporting the motion as
long as
it was agreed that in the report we
would mention
the interim study and then the what uh
representative thomas just mentioned
okay so what i had written actually a
lot of it is cribbed from the
original interim study is recommend for
future you know legislation
to form a legislative study committee be
a
a legislative study committee be
established to learn
which tests would be needed to which
need to be conducted to determine the
extent
of presence of hazardous materials
what kinds of remediation would be
expected and the cost of such
remediation
additionally this committee with advice
from experts could determine best
practice management practices
for opening new rail trails for
recreational use
and that can be tweaked too if that
doesn't cover everything
but that would be my initial interim
study report
comments thank you for doing that report
representative actually i'm reading just
check that off
yeah both of it is from the report that
was in the calendar
the consent calendar okay already so
um any other comments
yeah no i just wanted to say that that
i'm i'm
happy with that that statement right
do we need to go around the room with
that or are we all set
no i think we're all set okay
great um i'll ask the clerk to call the
roll
okay the motion is to recommend uh
hb 1426 for future legislation
vice chairman mays yes representative
spang
unmute
yes okay representative parkhurst
yes representative yvonne thomas
yes representative grassy
yes representative bushway
yes representative cohen yes
representative noel yes
the clerk votes yes representative wendy
thomas
yes representative renzullo yes
representative gould yes representative
horgan
yes representative feeney
representative feeney muted
yes representative gunski
representative harp yes representative
hobson
yes representative spelaine
chairman smith yes
and that will close the executive
session on house bill 1426.
i will refine my blo my committee report
uh representative rung and renzullo will
work
and will work on the uh report
for house bill 1316
and i and representative spang seems
like she wants to be involved in that
also
oh no no no reminding
i'm just reminding you that i oh no i'm
don't worry i know
i know um i just volunteer for
no you do you don't need to volunteer
for it i thought that's what you were
raising your hand for
um
now you made me forget what i was going
to say judah um
i just wanted to thank everyone
uh for all your hard work this last two
years
this is not the kind of going away party
at the end of session i wanted to have
uh usually you know we get together and
we have lunch or dinner
but obviously that is not going to
happen i appreciate everyone's hard work
we've had
a great committee both sides have worked
together
and gotten a lot done and with
many of our bills being on the consent
calendar and it's been really
great working with all of you um
and for those of you running for
reelection which i hope you
all are i know a couple who are not um
good luck with your campaigns
and i hope to see you in january
and well actually we have veto day too
but you know as a committee
this is it for us for the year and thank
you all for making the time to come here
today we are the first committee as i
said earlier to have
vote i had a work session on our interim
study bills and vote on them
so now uh joel and pam smarling and brad
greenland can go back and
say resources did it you should be able
to do it so
thank you everybody they're going to be
hated
thank you and representative smith thank
you so much uh for your leadership
you've been a great chairperson
and also to you chairman vice chairman
mays for
your support i think sometimes the vice
chair is often the unsung hero
but i know it was scheduling you guys
faced a lot of challenges so thank you
so much
i've been accused of a lot of things but
never an unsung hero
but i definitely i definitely want to
thank everyone and
and just to reiterate that this
committee has always been
policy over politics and i think that's
why we've been very successful
and we have the relationship we do with
all members of the committee so thank
you very much for that
and i also want to have a big shout out
to representative renzullo
he's been a easy to work with as a
ranking member hard to imagine sometimes
but we've been working well together
and now he's even giving me plants for
my garden so we have a great flavor
oh that's nice and uh representative
you undo your thing thank you everybody
for saying what you've said and who is
working on 1426 on the uh
comments uh i believe that that
is uh representative rum and yes
i may have a comment i'm not sure yet
okay yeah just
chucked in with with the two chairman
smith you better be careful of those
plants that andy's given you it's still
yeah hampshire you can go sell it in
massachusetts yes
he lives closer to the border he's in
charge of that part
representative cohen i see you have your
hand raised
i just want to thank you for your
leadership you ran a great
committee for two years uh you're a
shining example of how to bipartisanly
work things together and for the benefit
of all new hampshire people
well thank you again hopefully i'll be
working with you next year
it took all of us together to do it
um
it has been wonderful and i'm not sure
of my
coming back but if i do be wonderful if
i don't i'll say thank you to everyone
for supporting me and putting up with me
and
i love you all and have a good weekend
and well representative parkhurst for
some reason you
are not with us next year we're counting
on you to come in
to keep to visit and keep everybody in
the straight and narrow of
proper etiquette in the committee
thank you very much okay thank you
representative hobson oh thank you
am i muted okay no thank you very much i
have enjoyed working on this committee
um it's been a great committee for
all of us to be bipartisan and chairman
smith
chairperson smith you have done an
amazing job you've given all of us
equal opportunity to shine and i really
appreciate that
and uh henry i am not coming back if
you're not back
so if you get it you will not take it if
you to the clerk for a great job of
doing what she did
representative bushway um yeah i i
definitely won't be back
but i just wanted to say that i uh
thoroughly enjoyed my time
not only in the house but specifically
on this committee
it was a wonderful experience i learned
so much
and i am very grateful to having had
this
opportunity so thank you all very much
thank you and representative wendy
thomas
yeah i just want to echo what everybody
else is saying i want to thank
you suzanne for doing a fantastic job
and for
for leading and for teaching you you've
you've just taught
me so much being on this committee and
everybody else on this committee
um it was um you know being elected is
definitely trial by fire
i mean you're thrown into something
called a committee you're
you're asked to to you know defend bills
and talk about bills and
and um this fire was not as painful as i
had thought
it might be so um i really appreciate
and when i talk to other people about
you know politics i say that on our
our committee we we have agreement on
many many many bills
you know it really is i think kevin
talked it's
it's a bipartisan committee and i i just
have really enjoyed it and thank
everyone
for um for for just being there
and just being decent people thank you
thank you
and representative harp yes i want to
repeat
with representative thomas just said
this was my first committee as a
freshman legislature
and i am running again for office and i
hope to come back to this committee
and as uh representative may
said when people ask me how's your
committee and what's going on i believe
we do
in this committee act under principles
and policies
and it's not what party we belong to so
i've really enjoyed serving
it's been as you all said a learning
experience and i'm looking forward to
coming back
next year and i can see all the many
opportunities we have
to make a difference in our state thank
you
representative renzolo uh all this
kumbaya is killing me
obviously i didn't do my job
[Laughter]
but oh well i guess i'm just gonna have
to
go and hit myself
well blame it blame it on judith's
cookies she probably laced them and so
we're always
you know we're so happy because of her
cookie
oh i just i just thought we were just
normally a hoopie
anyway forget what i just said
it is a good committee and i tell people
that it is
and uh because part of it is just
getting along
and but also keep your principles and we
do do that
yeah yeah we can be we can disagree
without being too disagreeable
[Laughter]
thank you everyone bye-bye thank you
thank you see you soon
okay thanks john thank you thank you
joel
everybody's bailing out well everybody's
going to learn how to be